all right reza shaw's is back
oh my god and after how last season
ended
i was like can they go even come back
i am done i am done i am done there is
no more
necessary conversation oh
my god she's being crazy we have
30 years and you decided
to destroy it and you will never get it
back
talk to me about the journey forward and
how healing
has seemingly happened in the in between
first of all i don't know if god was
looking down
thinking okay i need to change the way
the world
works right now so res and mj can find a
way back to one another
to make sense out of it because the
pandemic changed everything for me
really
mj did extend the most beautiful olive
branch
out to me after the reunion and i'm so
grateful because i was able to see
her you know value and not see what had
happened
and really kind of for me forgive and
want better
so that the pandemic put things into
perspective for you
and then she made the first move to try
and repair things
absolutely immediately after the reunion
i went to see her
and we sat in the grass in her
neighborhood and we just like
reconnected i really after what you like
you said it was so horrendous
and i wanted to clean up as much of it
as i could
honestly it was like why are you
reacting
this is a human being that you love so
much
i needed to really figure out like what
was going on for you
so much that like you weren't able to
just drown the noise
out and uh let in the good stuff
and i never blame anything's on cameras
but like
when we are in you know
the mode where there is a camera in our
vicinity
let's just say um there's another
layer of pressure right and it's just
it's not anything that you're aware of
it's just something you feel and
i don't want to blame anyone other than
myself the pandemic
allowed me the silence to be able to
look at my life
and i'm writing a book it's called
memoirs of a geisha
get so
here i am bryce writing down all this
stuff
about my life and i'm finding that mj
was a part of so much of it
and um to be able to honor
the good things you have to somehow
reconcile
the devastation i have regret i have
perspective now you mentioned regret i
have to imagine you regret
pool party the comments made at the pool
party
your uterus exploded because you have 10
abortions
what the [ __ ] they're doing
obviously nothing but regret what was
the conversation like
what was the apology like i guess
because it has to be an apology
it wasn't just one apology you know
because
it's a lot of pain so it was like
apologizing
over time letting time pass and
there was goodwill and you know like
there would be a flare-up
and you know another apology might have
been required and it was a lot of kind
of like
establishing boundaries and more trust
and more good will
and it's been slow it's not anywhere
like it was before and it's not perfect
but i have to tell you from where we
were to where we are
now oh my god i have so much
gratitude i want to kind of tie up the
mj of it all
um and in tied in there is of course
tommy and the tommy situation
uh and from from the first looks we've
seen of the season he is still not in a
place
that he is willing to forgive you he's a
malignant tumor of a human
when i hear it it makes me think like
he's still angry
that means there's pain still and he has
different priorities bryce
he did he he has a child right
i don't have that so i don't want to say
that like oh
he should be where i'm at no i can't
assume to know what is going on
in his world i bless their home and i
hope that the temperature today or
tomorrow
is cooler than what we saw on the show i
really hope
it seemed a little too warm for my taste
but i prayed that like
time has brought it down since then
right i would imagine something like
sixish months
uh maybe some improvement has happened
since
those conversations were had we see in
the trailer you getting emotional
they've all met champs and i have it
have you had that chance at this point
so i don't want to give the delicious
like you know scoops that you guys are
gonna get to see during the season away
but i have to tell you he's
fantastically gorgeous he's so delicious
he looks like a mini mj
so you're gonna have to watch the season
let's stick up for each other and let's
be a group of friends that has each
other's [ __ ] backs
res is the one right now that needs some
lifting up how are you
and adam doing because that was your
relationship was wrapped up where are
you at right now
if you guys go on my instagram clearly
there's a pic of
us recently at the ojai valley inn so
it's not like
i'm giving away anything um
one of the things my argument with
mj and the devastation around all of
that
it forced adam to really step in
especially because of the pandemic
and pull a lot
of the weight that mj used to pull so
he really was loving where our new
relationship was
and how much communication we were
having and so for him
it really it created a lot of turmoil
the more mj and i made progress it
seemed like
it almost
the same thing that was happening in her
house was happening in my house
my husband just doesn't say those kinds
of things
i broke a plant i want there to break
his legs he's
lucky adam was the one who was pushing
for the restraining order against tommy
will we see where that is at this season
you share where things are at with that
you know i
like i said i don't want to give the
season away and you're going to see a
lot
of like talk about it
unfortunately because your boy has
bad bad habits
and forgets that his friend of 30 years
is not the person you talk to
first now you go to your husband
right and yes the whole thing happens
and the one thing i can say is
i'm about being accountable with mj and
tommy
i'm in that mode of i don't want to
fight but if we can grow
i'm here for it okay we're in for a ride
it seems
last thing one word what's your word to
describe
season nine brilliant it's my favorite
season so far
it's lit
[Music]